okay things stuff everything
all right today's what it is
i don't like that phrase anymore at all
[Music]
oh no hi my name is grace helbig if you
did not know now you know your life is
different now
welcome again to my kitchen it can only
mean one thing we're gonna have a
serious and uncomfortable political
conversation i'm just kidding we're
gonna cook
that's right we're doing a hello fresh
cooking video today
i'm very excited i'm slightly nervous
and ill-prepared
you want to hear something funny it's
not that funny it's actually kind of
boring and uninteresting but we're
friends and we talk
and a good friend listens even when they
assume that what their friend is saying
is so boring and unnecessary okay so
you're gonna have to practice being a
good friend right now i got all these
hellofresh meals sent to me
and i have made most of them almost all
of them
for actual dinners for myself and elliot
because i genuinely use this company
for my own real life and that's why i
like making these videos and i
saved one particular meal to make for a
video because i thought it was dumb and
fun and then right before
shooting this video i realized i [ __ ]
made meatloaf before
i made it a year ago for you guys if you
want to go watch that video you can
because we've made this before i'm going
to attempt to make it again
with a twist instead of making it as is
as the recipe suggests
i'm going to make it into cupcakes
because
it should be and why not this is the
democracy of my kitchen and
oh who votes for meatloaf cupcakes i do
it's
unanimous let's get into some talking
points we all love talking points right
hellofresh is i should know these by now
we're all doing the best we can how are
you
that i know that's not a good question
to ask people but i hope you are well
you're here and that to me signifies
that you're doing okay hellofresh is
america's number one meal kit you can
get really cool recipes with
pre-measured ingredients sent right to
your door it's a beautiful way to trick
the world into believing that you have
it figured out they got recipes
for all kinds of particularities yeah
they got low calorie they got family
friendly vegetarian sorry vegetarians
are not
uh doing that today and we focus and we
focus
what are you guys up to fans do hand
things they take the stress out of
cooking because we all know what's more
stressful than
participating in the world cooking with
a hello fresh recipe you can get a meal
on the table
in 30 minutes on average 20 minutes if
you get their quick and easy recipes
the sustainability aspect of hello fresh
is great they come with pre-measured
ingredients so there's less food waste
have you guys watched that david
attenborough
letter to the world about the world
being bad oh if you want to feel
a tremendous amount of extra guilt let's
save that we're guilt-free here in this
scenario
i'm the david attenborough of
now hello fresh unlike me is super
flexible you can change your delivery
days you can change your meal
preferences whenever you want they are
there to assist you in all of your needs
and hellofresh gives back in 2019 they
donated 2.5 million meals to charities
and they're looking to
up that amount this year so you can feel
good
about the whole thing all right talking
points out of the way look how
efficiently
this process is going let's get into the
part
that goes wrong meatloaf allah mom but
this time we're going in some cups
because who doesn't love
mom's cups all the ingredients come in a
handy dandy paper bag
no eggs but that almost hit my laptop so
as always
when i try to innovate something that is
already perfect as
is i have the idea loosely in my head
but i have not thought it through
completely
and everything looks fresh still even
though it's been in the refrigerator for
like a week
we're firing on every cylinder okay if
you're confident
nothing can go wrong and only things go
right preheat the oven to 425 degrees
wow i am a chef wash and dry all produce
oh self care getting all clean
pants are also a towel recipe calls for
making these potatoes into like wedges
but
because i want to put everything
basically together in like a little
cupcake we're gonna cut these up even
smaller talk amongst yourselves
the topic is uh
with something that will bring you
together and not divide you
oh gosh everything can be taken
terribly why don't we just sit in
silence the probability of this working
out is polling at like
80 percent yes and we all know we can
trust the poles potatoes have been cut
into
some little cubes put in a little bowl
half and peel the shallot we're gonna
mince half of it and grate the other
half i got high
hopes but that's probably just because
i'm high kidding
i'm not i save it till after because as
soon as i get a little too
i'm a little too you know thing i love
about you guys is that you
can get it don't forget the bag it came
in can be a trash bag
we love a transformation we're gonna
mince half of our shallot and if you
hear some heavy breathing
that's not my respiratory system goose
has entered the chat
i got one of these things let's see if
this works
oh watch your fingers wow
things are going well okay now we are
going to mince our garlic
the other great thing is that i thought
that this was a very fall
type of meal which is probably why i
made it a year ago fall
and um it's 95 degrees in los angeles
today
so watch out david attenborough doc
whoo yeah cool i'm
doing great now we take our time
and we strip the time loops from the
stems and then we roughly chop them
don't get too turned on strip get it
okay that was the alarm warning you to
calm that
boner down we've stripped we've graded
we've minced we've chopped so now
all the things that aren't potentially a
problem are done so now we get into
the real the real stuff this says toss
the potatoes on a baking sheet
with a drizzle of olive oil salt and
pepper and then you cook them for 20 to
25 minutes
what am i gonna do i'm gonna go forth
confidently into the abyss
we're gonna put them on this baking
sheet one of them
where'd you go to become an artist while
everyone else is going to med school
that's cool good for you let's
coat them all in this look wow just get
in there
wash your hands so we're going to put
the potatoes in the oven this says for
20 to 25 minutes but i'm gonna do less
than that because i cut them smaller you
you'll see how it comes together or you
won't because it won't
and uh in a bowl
we're going to combine grated shallots
yeah beef goes in
lovely garlic panko half of our chopped
thyme
salt and pepper look at this oh i'm as a
chef
and then we combine and again this does
not make me feel powerful it actually
makes me feel subordinate to the food
meat is combined wash your hands so this
is what i'm talking about
this is where the real magic happens or
the real tragic happens they're just two
letters off so we're gonna spray this
down i'm sorry david
let's start breaking off some little
chunks i want to leave some room for the
potatoes and green beans on top oh this
is so cute
bam all right brush the tops of the
meatloaf with one tablespoon of ketchup
divide this amongst our friends here
we care about everyone look at that
paint the tops paint the tap
let's put these in for five minutes
meatloaf's in the oven i'm gonna cut
these green beans up
smaller they cook faster and then put
them on this pan with olive oil salt and
pepper this is not the right way to do
it i'm rushing but i don't know what for
i don't know what i'm doing next i
should be slowing down to delay the
inevitable
in which i have to make a decision and
think critically about a
oh okay so our potatoes have been in
there for 10 minutes
let's just shake them and then keep them
cooking i guess oh
no some of them fell to the bottom
they're gonna burn that's okay if we
don't look at it it's not going bad
let's put the green beans in the oven
sure because i don't know what else to
do there's room for everyone
wash your hands that's one thing you
know that works so now we need to make
our gravy
this is not what a healthy confident
person looks like this is what a healthy
confident person looks like
we're going to take a half tablespoon of
butter in a pan over medium heat we're
going to add minced shallot add the
remaining chopped thyme
and cook stirring until the shallot is
softened for three to four minutes
add the flour stir to combine whisk in
the stock concentrate
half a cup of water and bring to a
simmer until
thickened then add salt and pepper that
looks like gravy
i mean it looks like a cat threw it up
and that's what gravy is right
this looks artistic and beautiful and
also wrong and foreboding so
neat i'm basically gonna let everything
in the oven cook until it looks done to
me
which is um and then when everything's
out
we'll put it all together i think our
actual meatloaves because they're
smaller have cooked all the way but
there's only one way to find out you eat
it and you
see if you made yourself sick that's the
only way we got our green beans we got
our potatoes here was the great
concept conceptualized now we got a bag
of cheese that is the size of my
whole head i'm now going to
be paralyzed with indecision for a
moment i'm going to put some potatoes
and some green beans onto our little
meat cakes then some cheese i'm going to
broil them
in the oven for a second the meat has
shrunk
it happens you'll get it someone coming
out tired of being in there
okay oh you're good i'm almost done no
no you want your privacy the hope is
that this
cheese acts like a glue i mean look how
cool this
is theoretically all right let's put
these in the oven let them broil for a
little bit till the cheese melts and
then see what kind of mess we've made in
total
check on it quickly because you don't
want to burn the cheese you burn the
cheese you're a domestic terrorist holy
[ __ ]
i think this kind of sort of did
something that is
interesting now i'm gonna take these out
try and put them on a plate and then put
some gravy on them oh my god oh my god
oh my god the gravy has congealed a
little bit but
oh my god these are [ __ ] mess that
are gonna put a lot of burden on any
guests you force
to attempt to eat these and that is okay
growth won't come unless you get a
little uncomfortable
[Music]
this is what she looks like on her
dating profile and this is how she shows
up and you're like
oh what have happened
and then you find out she's still your
rules welcome elliot look at this
wow meatballs yeah right this looks so
good
you really honestly think that it looks
like a little thanksgiving meal
yeah okay that is the plan your cadences
camera cadence camera cadence yeah would
you like to try one of these with me i
haven't actually tried it yet
i sure would grace thanks for offering
oh no before we try this and get messy
will you help me let them know what they
can get for watching this video i'd love
to
go to hellofresh.com use code hellbig80
and get a total of 80
off across five boxes including free
shipping on your first
box that's way better how big 80 80
off plus free shipping on your first box
ready to try this now
yeah okay i don't know if the meat's
cooked all the way but there's only one
way to find out so we just go like this
sounds like a little
yoda yeah it does cheers cheers
[Music]
really nice you want to do a fork okay
civilized it tastes great it's like a
salt bomb
it is a very salty uh yeah it might have
been a little overboard on the salt you
know you rather go overboard than
under board exactly now let's wind down
with some real
gentle and reassuring news no no thank
you guys so much for watching if you
like this video give it a thumbs up
subscribe to this youtube channel
we i make videos occasionally ellie and
i do podcasts occasionally it will come
back soon pilot on on his youtube
channel we've been busy
we've been busy thinking about lots of
different things you guys ever thought
about
the con the unconscious yeah that's a
lot of whatever honest conversation
something i'll see you guys next time i
don't know
however you could probably substitute
like ground um
beyond meat into this
beyond me is beyond me is that why
[Music]
okay we'll stew on that later